this is Trax and today we're gonna be
looking at some celebrity grills
[Music]
everybody has to have their grills if
they're in the hip-hop game if they're
doing something big grills have to be
molded specifically to somebody's teeth
and they have to be manufactured now
when you're working in somebody's mouth
you're putting your hands in there you
got to make sure you have gloves you got
to make sure you have the right
equipment you got to make sure you fit
it to the teeth correctly you got to
make sure you use dental gold you don't
want Tom Dick and Harry trying to make
you grills you want to make sure that
the people you're doing business with a
reputable and do the right job
oh so Paul Wall is a grills legend he's
got the princess cuts that's a very
difficult setting to do it's dangerous I
don't like doing princess cuts because
I'm always scared and I'm it's gonna
fall out crack somebody's tooth when
they're biting down on something
princess cut diamonds are essentially
square diamonds okay it's a nice
beautiful name for just a square shape
of a diamond and you take these diamonds
and you stack them like boxes side by
side so there's nothing in between and
that's called an invisible setting
meaning that there's no prongs holding
in the diamond the diamonds are wedged
together shoulder-to-shoulder that's
what's holding him in and there's bars
are gold underneath and sometimes when
the diamonds aren't cut properly or this
happens or that happens a diamond might
fall out if it falls out and it cracks
your tooth you're gonna have a big
problem because diamonds are very hard
and if you don't know you're biting down
with your full jaw strength thinking
you're gonna close your jaw like you
normally do and you crack your tooth in
half you're gonna be running to the
dentist screaming to get fitted for a
grill you got to make a mold the process
of getting a mold done well you have to
mix in two different compounds and that
you have 30 seconds or 40 seconds before
they dry so you put them in a special
mold put on your teeth press down the
real professionals they hit it with a
second layer that gives more definition
for the proper fit so that's how you get
your teeth molded and then it's
to the manufacturer to take it from
there to get you you're casting the gold
the right millimeter width for the right
size diamonds you don't want anything
damaging you and things like that lil
yachty so here you have little gotti
with a very unique very beautiful grill
set multi colors you got orange you guys
yellow you got blue now most likely the
orange and some of these colors are very
bright you got green those are sapphires
or some sort of gem but they're still
very high quality it's not a cheap job
the labor is very difficult the labor is
very high on that they had a beautiful
setting main and the craftsman that it
was working on those did a good job
huevo meet the second sample label
invisible began so these grilles right
here went viral these are Quay Bowls but
get grilles a baguette is a less
brilliant diamond that has less facets
they were in in the 90s they're back
back in the 90s jewelry was in its
infancy they weren't really that good
now we have high quality quavo only gets
the best he's a little bit of a guinea
pig though because these baguettes are a
new setting and if one of them falls out
it could cause a little bit of a problem
you can bite on it if you cut your
tongue you don't want to experiment with
it when you're doing that as grills it
has to be considered because you're not
just gonna go oops I lost my diamond
you're gonna have something that's as
hard as any material possibly out there
mixing in with your teeth that's a
dangerous situation
hopefully they did their homework on
these grills hopefully they did the
stress test and hopefully they got this
guy where he's not gonna be having any
type of problem but again these are
beautiful grills everyone wants them
everyone's a fan of them expensive
diamonds expensive setting very hard to
pick these out so that's another trend
for quavo
Trippi read so here you got trippy red
with the sharp teeth it's a little
ridiculous but if you're artists and you
want to look crazy might as well have
that shark teeth so you're gonna have a
bat and he's got inscriptions on it the
quality of the blue diamonds is very
high they're very bright I know they're
blue diamonds I know blue diamonds very
well sometimes you get such a real aqua
blue with like high quality diamonds so
that individual who's making those
grills wanted to keep him as a customer
and he's got letters on top so it's a
very intricate grill but you're not
gonna make a lot of sense when you're
speaking with sharp teeth
riff-raff before trip II read there was
riffraff riff rad had similar short
teeth these are more like piranha teeth
to be honest it's a very very sharp very
very crazy very very aggressive look
he's got a different type of blue
diamond there that knife quite is bright
but it's still a good setting and the
design is very very intricate however
you don't plan to bite your tongue off
or teeth like this in your mouth that's
a very dangerous thing to have don't go
get yourself some sharp teeth have a
couple of drinks get an argument and end
up going to the hospital
rules are not teeth do not eat with your
grills in your mouth don't chew gum with
them and even smoking is not preferable
if you're smoking you're gonna get the
same thing that happens to people's
teeth when they smoke do the same thing
that happens to their lungs you're gonna
get a film of tar that's gonna have to
be removed you're gonna get your girl's
dirty and then you're gonna have to get
them cleaned by a real jeweler Pharrell
Williams Pharrell with a very beautiful
enamel this is a very high quality
enamel piece who's got a lot of luster
to it
a lot of glow it's not like that plastic
dull enamel that's always good that's a
good material you don't want cheap
materials in your mouth especially when
they're made out of chemicals those are
very beautiful very well done
they look like 18 karat gold that's
another beautiful set that people would
love to see
ASAP Rocky ASAP Rocky's got the classic
yellow gold grills tops and bottoms
those might even be 18 karat dental gold
that's what they look like they were
done professionally these are not the
type of teeth you get at the mall
beautiful polish beautiful finish and
that's why he's so proud of them in his
photo and I would be too these are very
very nice and this is what your standard
gold tops and bottoms should look like
Travis Scott so here you have Travis
Scott with a very rare grill set an
invisible setting of chocolate diamonds
white diamonds pink diamonds and blue
diamonds very rare you don't see a lot
of pink diamond grills and especially in
this type of variety in color so I'm
sure he chose those colors himself I'm
sure that's the way he wanted it he got
in rose gold most likely hopefully
dental gold because rose gold can be a
little tricky but I'm sure they did
their homework when they did these girls
for him dental gold is a special type of
gold that doesn't have some metal alloys
there might be allergens it might not
have zinc or it might not have nickel
specifically to have in your mouth very
rare very interesting grill set
something that you're not gonna see
everybody have young ma so these are
young amazed grills I did them
personally so I know the quality we use
the best for her we like to keep these
people as customers we did a beautiful
prong setting for her sick mold of her
teeth with two layers of molding we
molded them once then we hit it with
another layer of a special type of gel
that gets all the details so the fit
would be comfortable against the gum
line so the gold doesn't press against
your gums no discomfort no inconvenience
from the business to the product to
anything else we make sure we take care
of our
people hundred percent so that's why
she's smiling and she looks pretty happy
little Wayne so little Wayne has got the
classic prong-set grill here the setting
on this one looks a little bit
old-fashioned he might have had it for a
long time he's a grilles originated this
particular is a classic he's got white
diamonds top and bottom a white gold
could be even platinum hard to tell the
setting could have been better but he
did start the trend these are probably
his original pair very very nice very
good pieces and clean white diamonds so
it's just a classic Kanye West you got
Kanye West here with six bottom teeth
fully iced he's got them flooded with
the yellow gold
it's a beautiful look if you don't want
to have the full mouth flooded out you
could get a couple of teeth done just a
touch it's more of an artistic sense
obviously this guy's known for his
artistic style and everything like that
so that's so what he's doing here and
it's a nice touch his subtle is just
right it requires a lot of experience in
the jewelry business to do jewelry
correct and you have to have
intelligence and you have to have a
determination that you're gonna do a
product that's gonna satisfy your
customer and not every jeweler has that
[Music]
you